ten
nine
eight
seven
six
five four
three
two
one ghost writer be on the page
great you're here welcome back to
ghostwriter beyond the page episode
two today we're going to become
explorers and journey through the lush
world beneath the tropical canopy of
the jungle book
however i think our journey is going to
be delayed a little bit because donna
has misplaced her bullet journal
somewhere in her bedroom
i i hope she finds it soon because she
needs it to write her story so let's
check in and see how she's doing
i know i had it when i was writing last
night
i knew it was in here somewhere
there's so many important things in here
i don't know what i would do without it
hey speaking of important stuff
i finished my character descriptions
okay check this out a smart young girl
with an amazing eye for color patterns
all things fashion they say write what
you know right she's talented at sewing
and weaving
but she has a hard time feeling like she
fits in
especially when her sporty older brother
treats her like a little kid in front of
all of their friends while i was
brainstorming i thought that there
should be a reason why sapphire my
character's name is so good at making
threads
and then it hit me
sapphire should be a spider and her
older brother spellman is a star soccer
player because with eight legs he can
really kick the only thing is the world
of a spider is so different than mine
i mean for them everything is literally
larger than life
i hope i can do her justice
here i even drew a picture of her
where
well that came out of nowhere
this has to be ghostwriter with more
help from my story
all right
let's see
where
well good thing i already found out
where my journal was
where
where
oh why
what are you looking for my friend
locally what a nice surprise
clearly ghostwriter knows i need help
donna just good to see you you too
mowgli
where are you
i'm exploring the jungle searching for a
new place to call home oh so you're not
with your wolf family
no
it has become important for me to
find a place of my own a new home
my wolf family will always love me and
be there for me and i will always be
part of the pack
but i must now spread my wings and find
a new place where i belong
somewhere that protects my wolf family
and my human family from sheer gone
and
somewhere i can truly become the human
cub i'm meant to be
wow
so it sounds like it's important to find
a place that you feel like you belong
yes exactly i think you can't really
know who you are if you
don't know where you belong
that makes sense
well i don't want to keep you from your
search yes i must continue before the
sun dips below the trees
take care donna
okay i really think i get this one what
mowgli said must be true
if where is so close to who
i need to figure out the where for
sapphire
i have to create a setting
i forgot that mowgli forges his own path
at the end of the book
but let's see what happens first ow
mowgli ruled over and was poked in the
back by a branch
he opened his eyes and sighed
he'd hoped to wake up safe and snuggle
between his sleeping brothers warm in
their fur
instead he was exactly where he was the
night before out in the middle of the
jungle chased off by his own pack twigs
and branches from the tents he'd made
tumbled onto his head mowgli gave a
sniff and rubbed his arm across his nose
why the long face friend a voice
chittered overhead
yeah why so sad call another voice
mowgli looked up
who's there
oh everyone
and no one
just us you see the monkeys
what in my world
sure enough several little monkeys with
wide grins peered down at him from the
trees
they dangled on matted wildly spiked
tails
mowgli had seen them swinging through
the treetops and nibbling on sweet
bananas
he'd wanted to play with them but his
mother disapproved she called them
little troublemakers
mowgli felt a pain in his heart at the
thought of his parents then shook it
away
they weren't here now
they told him to leave
they didn't have the right to decide
what he did anymore
as soon as he thought that he felt
ashamed
no
being mad at his parents wasn't the
answer
this was sheer khan's fault
cheer up one of the monkeys chirped
handing him a ripe mango
mowgli was surprised and a little
pleased to have someone looking out for
him
yeah cheer up called another monkey we
think you're cool
how did you make that log cave looks
quite snuggly geek
the first monkey nearly toppled out of
the tree as a large furry brown paw
knocked the trunk
oops a shaggy sloth bear lumbered into
view
i must have slipped
blue mowgli exclaimed happily why are
you here too
along with bagheera the lou was mowgli's
other best friend
the lou scratched his round belly
the gyro was worried about you wandering
off he explained patting mowgli's head
i showed up while you were sleeping last
night he left me to watch you until he
gets back
bagheera shouldn't worry mowgli said but
he was secretly glad his friends were
with him
i'm fine don't you have better things to
do
good friends never leave you alone
bagheera called from behind them
the panthers sauntered up and carefully
dropped a banana from between his teeth
eat that you're a growing cub
now
why were you talking to the monkeys
they seem nice mowgli said breaking off
a chunk of the banana and walking with
his friends
they gave me this mango
baloo sniffed
they seem nice for now just you wait
listen mowgli we've taught you a lot
about the ways of the jungle right
right
and we've never steered you wrong
right
of course mowgli said firmly you've been
my teachers for years
you guys know everything about the
jungle
that's right the gear up heard proudly
i never realized how much the jungle
book focuses on finding home
from the wolf pack to the monkey kingdom
to the village
there are a lot of important places
along mowgli's journey
i've got some thinking to do about where
my character will live
maybe she'll be trying to find it just
like mowgli well
let's dive right in
if you want to dive deeper into the
ghost writer world
be sure to read
the jungle book and then when you're
finished the jungle ghost section of the
activity guide
and of course be sure to check in with
the ghostwriter gang on apple tv plus
for episodes of the show
so thank you for exploring with me today
and i can't wait for you to come back
next time where we're gonna see what
donna and ghostwriter are up to next bye